[Music]
have y'all evolved your taste buds and
things that you liked over time
absolutely because like during the break
we were just talking about how things
that I work I was completely grossed out
like you know moving into Monterey Park
and stuff being introduced to Southeast
Asian food Chinese food the cooking
styles seeing like just straight animal
right it kind of freaked me out but now
I love it
I remember seeing for the first time so
I really had Vietnamese food and I moved
into this area and I was 15 and my
friend took me it was like trust me Maya
the best [ __ ] and it's all right
and I see for the first time and it was
like this honeycomb floating thing in
the little like yeah just like this
weird did you grow up like vegan or some
[ __ ] right my mom like my mom's
vegetarians I grew up eating like only
like vegetables at home and then the
very like clean-cut types of like meat
that you would get at school like a
hamburger you know it's a gonna shape
you know and it's I saw that bowl and
then just the smell of smell [ __ ]
crazy and so I didn't want to like be
not polite or impolite so I would always
just eat around it make it out of [ __ ]
the best part
I know but eventually I end up liking it
and now I like eating like all of it
like the crazier the weirder smelling
the weirder textures I liked all of it
now that's crazy because that's like the
most tame entry like yeah so tame that
like that's the main they call this a
stream no I mean I'm saying that's the
main thing that I did white people will
start liking right away and loving right
cuz that's it doesn't have any like that
fish sauce smell I don't like it I don't
like the fish sauce smell exactly we got
our white white person represented on
the authority I'm speaking for all why
do you get food you get any of that
crazy meat stuff I get beef or a steak
and that's it
rare steak no thank you I wanna cook
steak thank you no you know what for me
though like I I did like I think I
consider myself an adventure
either in terms of like a first-time
experience thing like I'm down to try it
but then to continue on and like be like
if I didn't like it I'm not gonna cuz
you get upset without me because I how
it really feels like fall separate Isis
you're like you like it we could eat
this all the time now and then you're
like oh yes yes let's go out and eat all
the crazy [ __ ] out there yeah let me try
it want man I did not let them on did
not because I'm like oh hell yeah let's
try it like dim sum cool crazy [ __ ]
alright there's chicken feet in Mexican
culture - um or when we went to go eat
I don't our first like not first we had
live Korean seafood right we did
there's chicken feet in my culture we
just we throw it away it was like live
see if they don't like whoa this is
crazy
like the novelty of it I guess I don't
know I'm not the novelty this one first
yeah so you just me with your food or
not slave but I'm just like oh this is
different like this is a different
culture I've never experienced or
whatever so that that aspect yes but
then when it's the first time I'm trying
Chinese food and it's in Dallas and I
have it for every single meal for a week
straight
and just all my parents really ever care
to eat you crazy and I kind of got a
little like okay can we not have changed
like carne asada we think that but at
Nikki with me because me and my family
we always get Mexican food and she's
like yo can we stop doing this [ __ ]
five days in a row your pair I mean your
family are they like predictable eaters
like they like their routine same things
it's Mexican food every single [ __ ]
time so how come that's not even white
people food
we never I mean dude growing up growing
of course but but when we went out it
was always Mexican food no matter so
when we were no I never what never
yes it's just this is what we all like
and we all liked it so it we all loved
it so it was just easy because of that
but yeah now we don't I don't I remember
being in Germany and being like I miss
just having like stuff that's true I
miss Mexican food because I think like
just being in LA you eat it so damn much
that you have to have it or else it's
lightning something's missing
Paco now we do but there was a long
period of time when we we didn't eat any
and I was just like I forgot my culture
I always try to cook everything even if
it's not like officially Mexican food
when I cook at home I find things a
little more like Mexican style like a
like salt pepper and then like some
chili powder or some cumin just to give
it like that essence just to make me
feel more at home
hopefully [ __ ] so putting words in my
mouth no but um but like talking about
like developing like different tastes
like this stuff yeah I do remember as a
child there were a lot of that specific
food items that I'm like that's nasty
who the hell would eat this like I
remember feeling like that about olives
and mustard and like vinegar sauce like
the salad vinaigrette Thank You
vinaigrette all right things like that
were like or mushrooms I thought I used
to think mushrooms were gross and like
now I love all I feel like it was a slow
transition or a singular moment that
flipped it I think it was like a
singular moment cuz like there would be
like I would avoid it avoid it avoid it
avoid it avoid it and then like somebody
like it will come up like if I'm eating
with someone and then they're they order
it or whatever I'm like you know what
it's been a long time I forgot what that
tasted like cuz I've been avoiding it
for so many years and then I'll try it
and I'm like oh [ __ ] it's good and then
but like in particular with olives and
mustard I remember I put it in a Subway
sandwich and I remember when I ate it I
was like I am now an adult because I
remember thinking like as a kid like
only adults like these flavors and I'm
and then when I ended up liking it I'm
like there are adult things though that
just like you don't want as a kid and I
don't think I ever want like you have
you have bitter melon oh yeah I don't
sounds like there's no time I've ever
tried it have I ever been able to figure
out any like pleasurable quality about I
don't get I can eat it if I don't crave
it like if it's there to get you I'm
just like I'll eat it but it's it's it's
a little rough when you eat it I don't
get any melon even warm on melon it's a
different game yeah it's like why would
a human eat this and why would they even
continuously eat this enthrall this and
tend to it like what why would someone
don't dinnertime go aha bitter melon mmm
like they're craving it and they go by
that's why I feel about tonic water I
like who likes tonic well it's bigger
gusting why is it like that why don't
they just get club soda right bitter
like club soda rural I I guess I don't
know because I've never had it by itself
I've only had it in general sure I never
drank tonic water by yourself is pretty
bad really it doesn't taste like gin and
tonic that's for sure so the magic of a
gin and tonic is the two things Terrace
with a little bit of lime any magic to
me like they only invented it for gin I
feel like for me I had a singular moment
in my life I remember I was I was a kid
I was extremely close minded not just
with food but with activities anything
new I hated like and in typical child
yeah it was anything and it lasted for a
long time probably till I was 16 or
something and I remember the moment - it
was weird I was on a plane flying
somewhere and I was looking out at the
clouds and I was like it wasn't just
food it was like I didn't ride
rollercoasters cuz I was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I didn't do anything that outside
of what I would do on a daily basis so
you're a very routine and like predict
yeah so even if I went to Six Flags I
just wouldn't go on I was like roller
coasters now that's [ __ ] crazy what
the [ __ ] did you do it no I was in the
next time I went to Six Flags I wrote
everything it was I don't know
I was just staring up in this quiet I
was a fool with the shape of the clown I
was staring out into the clouds I've
arrived I felt like uh like you guys
know the Buddhist story it's a doctor
yeah yeah like the prince yeah and he's
like he's living in luxury and then he
just decided to go into the forest and
surprise nothing
I mean reached enlightenment right yeah
so I tell like it was like that it was
away I was like this moment where
flipped a switch and I was like you
should try everything
yes sixteen listen to my teachings yeah
but yeah yeah you know just a singular
moment where I was just like why am i
turning all these things down even
though I've never tried it before
it's not funny that you reached
enlightenment and when Riddler's revenge
[Laughter]
I'm going straight to Six Flags to like
I wouldn't eat mushrooms or whatever
wouldn't like it was anything that I had
never had like before but then what
about if you tried it and you just still
didn't like it I just wouldn't try it I
was astonished Lyra Fugit so you just
didn't try before you even yeah I just
wouldn't do any oh [ __ ]
I was extremely stubborn how old are you
like probably like sixteen sixteen you
didn't do anything did you have any
friends yeah yeah I would do the things
I just stood that was okay and what do
they do so like what what's your deal
why'd you pay to come to such a complete
loser
do you think you are just scared of
everything yeah it was a lot of fear a
lot of like what is that body unknown
yeah yeah you were the guy that held
everyone's phones and hats and stuff
yeah like sitting there by yourself with
all the peanuts I was like you guys what
my [ __ ] I'm gonna go on the ride
I've been deprived of this yeah I was I
was really really scared of roller
coasters or that g-force feeling in my
stomach
I remember being terrified of it because
when I was really little my dad like in
the swing sets I remember he would like
really throw me [ __ ] he would launch me
where out good too much and then my
uncle too like he would grab me by my my
arm and
leg like this and then like swing me
around and like it was fun in the
beginning but then he'd go like too
rough where I'm like I can't think I
can't breathe I hate it I hate this
[ __ ] g-force feeling I hate it and
then one time I went to Six Flags with
my mom and then it was for Mother's Day
so the whole time we were like in the
kiddie section and then she was like
please go get a one roller coaster like
it's Mother's Day like yeah and then I
was like okay fine
and she's like okay but I get to pick it
and I'm like okay Oh Superman Goliath
she wanted to go uncle Wyeth that's in
six legs right or is it not yes right
okay so then we end up getting on the
lion and I was like [ __ ] panicking I
was like no it isn't like at the top of
the roller coaster I put my face down on
my my thigh cuz I'm like yeah my moms
like get up get up and see and then
that's when like it drops and then in
that moment oh they really could not get
up cuz the g-force just locked into it
it did that was like screaming and I
couldn't get up but then for some reason
that traumatic experience made me love
roller Kings roller coasters you're like
I didn't die yeah the breakthrough think
that's what it was did you go on more
after that
yeah that's how it was like closing time
so we didn't get to go on more but the
next time I went to a theme park I was
just like okay like give me like I want
that feeling forever I used to look
forward to closing times and when I was
still afraid of roller coasters of like
relieving cuz it's closing we're gonna
say because there's no lines there was a
time when I hated roller coasters too
and like I'm like I'm getting on every
single line doesn't matter how many
times I've gotten on the roller coaster
gave me like huge anxiety and like I
didn't want to [ __ ] out though in front
of my friends I was just like I'm pretty
sure I'm not into roller coasters at all
cuz of the anticipation but afterwards I
[ __ ] loved it but then the
anticipation happens again yeah
repeat a terror yes but but yeah Bev
yeah we and you know them you kind of
learn to enjoy that terror I was I got
older I've [ __ ] hate him even more
I've never learned to enjoy the
anticipation or the terror any of this I
just hated waiting so long that's what
pissed me off waiting yeah because I
waited so long for the ride and when I
think it's like it's like two minutes of
a ride yeah yeah and you have to wait
like one hour yeah I wanted that Harry
Potter [ __ ] dragons ride that [ __ ]
was a hell ride bro
yeah the Blue Dragons versus the
whatever dragon in Orlando Florida
Oh No thank you again I I didn't have my
glasses on I know where the I was
nighttime no what the [ __ ] was going on
or where I was you could have been on
Space Mountain yeah right yeah I could
have been inside a mother's womb I had
no idea what was going on